well the headlines story about Darfur is
that we and a dozen other major NGOs
have been expelled from Sudan and that's
from all of northern Sudan Darfur and
we've also been active in the north and
the east of Sudan and that's a major
crisis that is in the making right now
because there's no question that the
expelled NGOs have been the pipeline for
most of the assistance that has that has
been going into Darfur so maybe to go to
your initial question what kind of
assistance is that the in Darfur they've
been 3 million people displaced about
300,000 of those have gone across the
border mostly into Chad but the rest are
in a sense trapped within Darfur and
they are in large settlements in which
that are very inhospitable these are
people who have always been able to take
care of themselves they've grown their
own food they've had their own village
structure I visited some of these
villages that were have been burned out
and it's clear that these militia
they're called Janjaweed they were
coming on camels and on horseback and
they have simply destroyed the villages
and burn the farms poisoned the wells
raped the women of these in these
villages and so they have fled and they
are in these large camps for displaced
people and the distrust of by on the
part of the people in these camps of the
Sudanese government is extremely high so
even if it were a feasible for the
Sudanese government to get food and
health care and educational programs and
water and sanitation into these
settlements the residents would be
extremely resistant because they are
completely convinced the reason they're
in those camps is because their own
government has allied itself with these
militia that have driven them from their
homes so what when we first we had been
in southern Sudan for about 20 years a
southern Sudan is an area that is pretty
autonomous from the north and we had
worked in southern Sudan and when the
the fighting broke out in Darfur we were
able to move in very quickly along with
a few other NGOs save the children of
Great Britain doctors without borders of
France and Holland and we the need was
so great that we were able to in a sense
agree on who would be in which of the
various geographical regions and what we
did is what we always do when we go into
an emergency we we provide water and
sanitation on an emergency basis but
then we then very quickly try to provide
basic health care begin educational
programs the World Food Programme of the
UN brings food in we don't usually get
involved in food distribution although
under very dire circumstances will do
that and we've been doing that now since
2004 when when Darfur blew up we will no
longer be doing that so we're working
very hard to transfer the the capacities
that we have developed in our Sudanese
staff to other NGOs including Sudanese
NGOs but it is the Sudanese government
has made it very difficult for us to do
that are all of our assets on the ground
or vehicles or computers or other
facilities have been seized and have
been locked up we have we have at the
time that the Sudanese government issued
these expulsion orders we had only three
international staff left in Sudan
outside of the south in northern Sudan a
Brit and and to Kenyans and those three
are still in Sudan there in a sense
being held hostage we had 600 Sudanese
staff who were now all without work
because the Sudanese government has
forced us to cease operations so we are
working on a number of fronts we're
trying to see if we can find employment
for the staff who were working with us
because they've learned a lot over the
four or five years that we've been
active in Darfur and they had skills
that would be very much needed going
forward and we're also trying to assure
that the beneficiaries have depended on
the assistance that we've given we'll
have other providers but that is going
to be very difficult to achieve given
the fact that the largest providers of
these services have all been expelled
you